[拍手]
僕は今日ここでするプレゼンテーションは皆さんが主人公です
ぜひ自分のことを想像しながら聴いてください
僕たちはこれまでさまざまな選択をしてきました
鋸南の服を着ようとか今日何を食べようのようなへ地上的な選択から進学や就職など
重要な選択もしてきました
このような中で皆さんは
こんなはずじゃなかったなぁとかワクワクしない
ラメたいなぁなどを持って後悔したことはありませんか
おそらくほとんどの人がこのような経験あると思います
ではもしこのような選択で出来る限り
後悔のない選択方法があるとすると皆さん知りたいと思いませんか
僕はもう知りたくて知りたくてたまりませんでしたそしてあるひとつの方法に辿り着き
ました
今日はそのアイディアについて話させてください
僕はまずこの方法を探すにあたって自分の失敗から振り返ってみました
初めての彼女との初めてのデートのお店を選択したときの話をさせてください
当時彼女は僕にこう言ったんです
おしゃれなパスタが食べたいん
でも僕の頭の中ではこう思いました
+ためっちゃオシャレやんって思ったんです
僕は田舎者の少年でパスタといえばミートスパゲッティだったんです
だからパスタっていう言い方でさえもえめっちゃを者やんって思うような少年でした
そんな少年に対して彼女はおしゃれなパスタが食べたいと言ってきたんです
僕はばて丁寧に帰ってインターネットの検索画面にパスタと入力してみたんです
そうするともう食べたこともないおしゃれなパスタがたくさん並んでいて僕は
ワクワクしましたそしてどうせなら彼女も絶対に知らないパスとを食べさせてやろうと
思ってたくさん調べたのです
そして見つけましたおそらくこの会場の誰も知らない
イタリア人レベルの人しか知らないような超絶マニアックなパスタをさ
見つけたんです
僕は彼女を呼び出しデートに行きましたん
2人はドキドキしながら料理やくるのを待っていると店員さんがやってきて僕たちの目
の前だした料理がこちらです
赤羽とです
打ったになると見ての通り魚の料理なんです
この白目が何とも言えないですよね僕のが勝目でした
なんじゃこれパスタじゃないとなりました
この時僕は彼女に白彼女も知らないようなパスタを食べさせたいというシーンで気が
ついたらおしゃれな名前を探していたんです
もう大失敗です
僕は今のような大失敗をした経験から選択で公開をしやすい
あるパターンについて気がつきました
それは
自信がある選択肢がない時にやっていきます
自信がある選択肢がないとき人は無理やり選択肢を増やそうとすると思うんです
そして周りから情報を集めますその情報に含まれるデフォルト正しいと思い込み
選択をするというパターンです
ここで過ごしデフォルトについて説明させてください
デフォルトは初期設定や行動を起こさない状態といった意味を表す言葉です
そして僕はこの世の中の殆どのものがデフォルトだと考えています
人類が一番最初に出会うデフォルトは
生まれた時と両親です最初の設定は誰にも代えられません
その時から人は人生が進むにつれてさまざまなデフォルトに出会います
空が多いということもデフォルトです
飛行機が飛ぶということもデフォルト先生からの言葉や両親からの言葉も僕は
デフォルトだと思っています
だから僕はパスターを検索した時両親にインターネットの方法を聞いたんです
そうすると両親は僕にとりあえず検索画面にパスとと入力したらあとは全部パスタが出
てくるから頑張れと教えてくれたんです動くはそれを正しいと思い込んで鵜呑みにし
ました
これがもしかすると僕が失敗した原因の1つかもしれません
さらに例を挙げます
皆さん大学受験について思い出してみてください
大学受験では学部と学科を選択すると思うんです
僕は当時
あ学部と学科を選択すると思うんです
その時もし本当に心からワクワクする自信の持てる選択肢はなかったとしてください
そうすると人は無理やり選択肢を増やそうとします
そして周りから情報を集めます
これはインターネットで検索をしてみたりとか
先生や両親にアドバイスをいただいたりすると思うんです
例えば機械系や情報系は就職がし痩せようとか
高い偏差値の大学に行くと高いお給料をもらえるようとかですかね
でもこのような情報って皆さんのデフォルトによって変わると思うんです
もしその人の先生が違う人だったら
もしその人の良心が違う人だったら違う情報が入っているはずです
つまり僕たちは巣は糸のデフォルトによって変わるかもしれない
情報を鵜呑みにし正しいと思い込み
学部や学科のような重要な選択をしてしまっている可能性があります
そしてその後にその情報が阿蘇の選択が正しかったかどうか気がつくんです
ではどうすれば僕たちはできる限り後悔のない選択をすることができるんでしょうか
8年前の話です僕は理系と文系を選択している時でした
当時文系の偏差値の方が数学の偏差値よりも高かったんです
周りの友達は理系数学の偏差値が高い人は文系に行き
数学の偏差値が低い人は理系に入ってました文献言ってました
つまり
僕のこの時のデフォルトは完全に文献に行けと言っています
でも僕には夢があったんです
掌握を6年生の時です
初めて両親に飛行機に乗せてもらいました
もう期待にが浮く瞬間にもワクワクが止まらなかったんです
なんでこんな鉄の塊が飛ぶんだとワクワクしました
行き先はドイツだったんですが行きも帰りもほとんど寝ていません
この時から僕の夢はパイロットになりました
だから2型選択をしたんです
今となってはアメリカで研究をしたいと思うぐらい
僕は理系科目が大好きになりました
ではもしこの時本当に僕は心から枠は数ある選択肢がなかったらどうなっていた
でしょうか
おそらくデフォルトである文献に行くべきだというものに従っていたと思います
この経験から僕が学んだことは
もし出来る限り後悔のない選択をしたいとき
何かを選択する前に本当に自分が心からワクワクする選択肢を持っていることが重要だ
と思ったのです
とはいっても皆さんの中にはこのように思ってる人がいるかもしれません
わくわくする興味があるものがないから困ってるんだよ
よく聞きます
今日はここがとっても重要です
確かに僕の場合はデフォルトである両親にパイロットというワクワクするものを
プレゼントしてもらいました
だから僕は両親にとっても感謝をしています
でもなかには生成や友達などからワクワクするものをプレゼントしてもらった人もいる
と思います
でもこのような物って運みたいなものかもしれません
だってもしその人に合ってなかったらそのワクワクはなかったかも知れませんよね
だから僕は思ったんです結局バクバクできるかどうかって
うんじゃんって思ってしまった時期がありました
そして考えました
うんみたいな哀れからの影響によるものではなく自分自身でワクワクできる選択肢を
増やせる方法はないかなと思ったんです
そしてその方法は今僕の趣味となっています
そのアイディアは
世の中のデフォルト疑い問題を自分で作り
解いてみるということですつまりこれはワイハうわっどの順番で考えてみるということ
です
例えば小学生が飛行機が飛ぶというデフォルト疑ったとしましょう
そうするとまずなんで引越を受けて飛ぶんだろうと
問題を作りますその後に飛行機が飛ぶ原理を知るためには
物理学というものを勉強しないといけない物理学を勉強するためには数学が必要だ
数学をするためには算数をしないといけないと思います
だから今自分が学校でやってる算数を把握やれたいってなると思うんです
僕はこれが人が興味を持つ本質だと思います
人は疑問があるから知りたくなるんですしれたいから勉強したり調べたり寿司たくなる
んです
でも僕たちはこのプロセスがいつのまにか
逆転してはいないでしょうか
まず一番最初にマッドとしてでフォルダーがインプットされます
英数国車あり勉強しないといけないでもその英数国シャーリーを勉強しているときに
それが世の中に対してどのように使うことができてなんで今それをやってるのかって
本質的に理解しながらやっていた人はどれくらいいるんでしょうか
おそらくほとんどの場合がその後になってからこのホワイトハウに気がつくんじゃない
でしょうか
そして公開をするというパターンもあると思います
例えばこんなところに数学って使うことができたのか
ちゃんとあの時数学勉強していけばよかったなーとか思ったことある人いませんか
このように僕たちはいつしか
この世の中に疑問や好奇心を抱くことなく
予め用意されたデフォルトに従って生きていないでしょうか
そして進学先を決めなければいけない就職活動をしないといけないという状況になって
から売れ選択肢を増やし
売りあり選択する
そしてある時に自分がやりたいことをやっていないことに気がつく
その繰り返しかもしれません
この二のパターン終止符を打てるかもしれないアイディアがこの世の中のデフォルト
疑い
問題を自分で作り解いてみるということなんです
この愛では11個の愛では難しいかも知れませんので一度皆さん一緒にやってみ
ましょう
これはある駅の写真です僕が最近にとってきました
この中で皆さん1度デフォルト疑ってみてください
少し時間を取ります
デフォルトを疑うということは当たり前を疑うということです
この中でたくさん y をつくってみてください
a ですかね
例えばこのトイレの映画等僕たちは普段
男性はオイルね女性は回路というデフォルトがインプットされていると思います
だからこの人形のマークがなくても男性が青色に入り
女性が赤色に入ると思うんですなぜでしょうか
そう考えると色には不思議な力があります
僕が一番最初に選択したアクアパッツァが紫色で出てきたら彼女はおそらく一口も食べ
ずに帰ってしまったかもしれません
を貼っ曲です
そう考えると人が一番美味しそうに見える色って何色なんでしょうか
人が一番惹きつけられる色って何色なんでしょうか
このように日常に問題を作ってスマートフォンで調べていきます
皆さんも今日の帰りに行ってみてください
そしてこのデフォルト疑うということに慣れてくると今度はその
デフォルト自分だったらどう変えるだろうと考えることができるのです
例えば n 皆さん1度を思い浮かべてみてください
皆さんが慌てて電車に乗ったとします
パッド顔を上げると優先座席に若い女性が座っていてその目の前にとっても辛そうな
老人が立っているとします
そういうシチュエーションを思い出してみ思い浮かべてみてください
デフォルトから女性はなんでこの
ご老人に席を譲ってあげないんだろうっていう問題を作ったとします
そうすると最終的には心理学みたいなものに来て付くかもしれません
では次はどうしたらその泥者というデフォルトをどう変えたら
女性が立つのだろうと考えてみてください
どう思いますか
例えばその優先がせよう
体重計に設計してみたらその女性は立つんでしょうかそれともこのように少し体重体重
を5万しかしながらでも座るんでしょうか
これに別に答えなんかないんです実現可能性なんてどうでもいいんです
ただその時に空間設計と面白いなーって思うかもしれません
電車で言いますとなぜ新幹線はとかっていて普通の電車は四角いんでしょうか
流体力学を勉強したらわかるかもしれません
そして電車の中でも中の設計と外の設計は私がいます
電車の中の設計は
磯の配置や広告の配置などを決めたりする空間的な設計で外の設計は空気抵抗などを
考える
光学的な設計です
どちらに興味を持つかは人次第ですけれども
電車だけでも
様々な仕事や様々な学問に受け付けます
なぜ電車を連挙げたというとみなさん
電車の中では普段何をしていますか
もし電車の中で時間をつぶす保護集中だよという人や
この今日の帰りに前電車につかまって
ただつり革を持っている時間になった時には今日のこのアイデアを一度思い出してみて
ください
そして騙されたと思ってこのデフォルト疑うということをやってみてください
本当に電車の中はワクワクの塊なんです
そして最後にこの
世の中のデフォルト疑い問題を自分で作り
解いてみるということについてくるリスクについてお話させてください
そのリスクは
洗濯をするときにどうしても少数派になり
批判を受けてしまう可能性があります
僕の経験上はこのような言葉をかけられるかもしれません
普通じゃない
絶対に無理だそっちの道を行くなんてもったいないよとか馬鹿じゃないのとか言われる
ことがあります
このようなことでを言われることによって本当に心からワクワクしている自分が自信を
持っている選択肢があるにも関らず
また違う選択をしてしまう可能性があります
この時のために僕が今一番大事にしている言葉を共有させてください
その言葉は
妻は徒であるということです
別に他人と違う道を行くことは
怖いことではありません
た年と違う道を行くことは妻が生まれていて価値が生まれているんです
希少価値が生まれているんです
だからもし皆さん本当にワクワクする
心から自信の持てる選択肢があって批判をされたとしても
ああ今妻が生まれているは今価値が生まれてるわーと思ってください
そして自信を持って自分が本当にワクワクするうちに進んでください
そうするとその先の道もきっとワクワクの連続であると僕は思います
ありがとうございました
[拍手]